how are y'all doing doing well good how
are you I'm well thank you y'all are
glowing you look fabulous oh my goodness
I like your backdrop everything thank
you we're bringing the brightness the
sunshine thank you appreciate you well
listen y'all we gotta jump into this
because I mean sci-fi comedy I mean
mystery y'all are serving it like let's
be honest
cool things it is a mashup of all things
like your Dynamic was incredible so I
gotta know who out of the cast brought
the most laughs on set
ciao
oh you don't want to claim this is Jamie
it's Jamie okay all right sure for sure
was it hard to keep us uh light fun
professionalism we got free stand-up
shows that you would normally pay 29.99
so you know sang some songs all of that
[Laughter]
listen y'all got a full show there okay
there was honestly like you could tell
that y'all were genuinely laughing there
was one part where I had to like Catch
My Breath because I was just laughing so
hard with y'all
um was there a lot of AD living on this
film
we definitely ad-lived quite a bit
um but I think we also did well with
honoring what the script what was on the
page what Joelle and Tony wrote and the
same with Jamie uh we we did what was
there and then from that point on you
know joelle's like yo make it yours make
it crispy man you know whatever yeah
play
um and
when you're dealing with an amazing
talent and comedy comedic genius like
Jamie you just gotta let them do what
they do
um and so you know
well you kept up just fine you kept them
just fine trust well listen speaking of
Jamie you know I gotta ask have y'all
talked to him how's my man doing is he
is he out here is he thriving talk to me
yeah it's all good he's all good so yeah
he's just gonna wait for him to reappear
when he wants to you know privacy
to heal how they need to do yeah that's
right absolutely well I gotta know do
y'all think cloning is real like you
think these scientists are out here and
actually know that all of this cloning
is real
I mean it it's not a secret or a
conspiracy that they are cloning like
cloning exists in the world yes humans
that's a different story it's a whole
different story
okay okay all right okay well I have to
know in terms of cloning speaking of
your cast mate Jamie if you could clone
one of his characters which character
would you clone
um
I like the thought that's going into it
because I'm like not slick slick gets on
yo-yo's nerves on that one right
who's the lawyer who played in just
Mercy
[Music]
yeah just in case because I was a good
lawyer right
I know because a lot of them you're like
but it was dirty yeah Electro when he
played it yeah they love their movies a
w that character walking around I don't
know child yeah okay all right okay
we'll save that for later you get back
to me I'll be here it's fine it's fine
so listen what do y'all hope that the
audience takes from this film what's the
message that you want them to take after
they watch they clone Tyrone
um it's it's an exploration of you know
where blame and responsibility the
meet and where they don't where they
intersect and where they don't
um so having conversations around that
having a good time being entertained I
pray that that is something ultimately
that they leave with uh whether whether
they want to have these philosophical
discussions about
conspiracies and
socioeconomic cycles that are impossible
to get out of or are they impossible
whether they want to do all of that I
hope they have a good time yeah
absolutely well thank you all so much
for this film I'm really really excited
for the world to see it so I appreciate
y'all thank you thank you